HAVE A REPEAT OF LAST NIGHT.
WE WILL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> Tucker: THANKS SO MUCH.
IF YOU’VE BEEN WATCHING THE
COVERAGE, YOU KNOW PERFECTLY
WELL THAT WHAT’S HAPPENING ON
THE STREETS NO MATTER WHAT IT
MAY LOOK LIKE IS ACTUALLY A
QUEST FOR JUSTICE.
IT’S A LONG OVERDUE SEARCH FOR
ANSWERS WHO IF WE ARE GOING TO
BE HONEST ABOUT IT HAVE BEEN
OPPRESSED FOR SO LONG THEY CAN
NO LONGER STAND IDLE.
HERE WAS THE REPRESENTATIVE SEEN
LAST NIGHT.
>> THIS IS THE CRAZIEST STUFF
I’VE EVER SEEN RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS TARGET RIGHT NOW.
>> NOW WAIT A SECOND, YOU MIGHT
BE THINKING.
THAT DIDN’T LOOK LIKE A
POLITICAL RALLY, THOSE DON’T
EVEN LOOK LIKE LOOTERS.
THEY WERE SMASHING CASH
REGISTERS TO STEAL OTHER
PEOPLE’S MONEY.
YES, TECHNICALLY THEY WERE DOING
THAT AND AS A FACTUAL MATTER
THEY WERE SMASHING CASH
REGISTERS BECAUSE THEY HAD
ALREADY STOLEN EVERYTHING ELSE
IN THE STORE.
SO, NO.
IT DOESN’T LOOK LIKE POLITICAL
ACTIVISM, IT LOOKS IT’S NOT LIKE
WAS SOMETHING IMMORAL.
>> BLACK PEOPLE’S RIGHT TO
PROTEST IS SECONDARY TO WHITE
PEOPLE’S RIGHT TO PROTEST WITH
THE LONG GUNS AND TERRIFYING
LOOKING FOR WEAPONS.
>> THIS IS HOW FLOYD’S DEATH
ENDED UP.
POLICE IN RIOT GEAR FLOODING THE
STREETS WITH TEARGAS AND
SHOOTING RUBBER BULLETS INTO THE
GROUND.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF HOW THIS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN KIND OF A
BLACK LIGHT EXPOSING ALL THE
INEQUALITIES.
AND THEY ARE ANGRY AND, OTHER
FOLKS ARE EXPECTED TO BE
OBEDIENT.
>> THEY ARE OUT THERE WITH
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS AND THEY WERE
TREATED WITH KID GLOVES.
>> Tucker: YOU SEE IT’S NOT AT
ALL LIKE THOSE FACETS IN
MICHIGAN.
IN MINNEAPOLIS, THERE’S A REASON
PEOPLE DO IT, A LEGITIMATE
REASON.
THEY WERE CIVILLY SMASHING THE
CASH REGISTERS.
THEY ARE PROBABLY EUROPEAN CASH
REGISTERS, AND EUROPEANS CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY AND THEY CREATED
WITH THEMSELVES EVERY MAN, AND
THAT’S OKAY, AND THE POLICE ARE
BENIGN.
THEY DON’T EVEN ACT AFRAID.
BUT LET BLACK PEOPLE SHOW UP AND
PROTEST THE DEATH OF AN INNOCENT
BLACK MAN AND SUDDENLY WE NEED
TEARGAS.
THE POLICE ARE THERE TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE EMERGING AS
NEO-NAZIS, NOT TO PROTECT THE
BLACK PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: IT’S SO WHO WATCHES
JOEY READ?
IT TURNS OUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN MINNEAPOLIS.
THEY DECLARED THAT RACISM IS "A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
MEANWHILE, MOBS IN DOWNTOWN
MINNEAPOLIS KEPT LOOTING, STORES
KEPT BURNING.
AND THEY WERE STEALING PLAY
STATIONS FROM TARGET.
THAT’S THE NEW STANDARD.
NOW THAT WE ARE IN A STATE OF
NATIONAL EMERGENCY THE QUESTION
IS, WHAT’S NOT ACCEPTABLE?
WHAT’S NOT OKAY?
ANYTHING?
HERE’S WHAT SOME OF THE
"PROTESTERS WERE CHANTING LAST
NIGHT IN MINNEAPOLIS.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE THAT CLIP
ON CNN, HOW COME?
FACTS LIKE THIS, AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF THEM, CHALLENGE THE
CAREFULLY CONSTRUCTED STORY
LINES OUR LEADERS PROFIT FROM.
PRACTICALLY EVERY DAY WE ARE
TOLD THAT WHITE COPS ARE A
MORTAL THREAT TO BLACK MEN AND
SOME ARE OBVIOUSLY, A BLACK MAN
WAS KILLED BY THE POLICE, IT’S
AWFUL.
BUT WHAT ARE THE NATIONAL
NUMBERS ON THIS?
NET NATURALLY WE KNOW THE
ANSWERS.
WHITE POLICE OFFICERS WERE LESS
LIKELY TO SHOOT AND KILL
NONWHITE SUSPECTS THAN NONWHITE
POLICE POLICE OFFICERS WERE.
IN ANY GIVEN YEAR POLICE KILL
MORE WHITE SUSPECTS ARMED AND
UNARMED THAN BLACK SUSPECTS.
AND THAT’S A FACT BY THE WAY,
NOT POLITICAL PROPAGANDA, IT’S
PROVABLY TRUE.
NO ONE ON TELEVISION WILL EVER
SAY THAT BECAUSE THAT FACT
THREATENS THE SCAMS THEY ARE
WORKING.
EDDIE CLOW JR. MIGHT BE THE
LIVING EMBODIMENT OF THIS
PHENOMENON.
IF YOU’VE EVER WONDERED IF
YELLING EXIST AT THE PEOPLE YOU
WANT SOMETHING FROM IS AN
EFFECTIVE BUSINESS PLAN, HE IS
LIVING PROOF THAT INDEED IT IS.
BY REGULARLY SCREAMING "RACIST"
HE’S BEEN ABLE TO WRITE AN
ACADEMIC CAREER ALL THE WAY TO
AN ENDOWED PROFESSOR AT
PRINCETON.
IT’S A JOB WITH SUCH HIGH PAY
AND SO FEW ACTUAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT DOWD CAN DRESS LIKE A
BRITISH LORD AND SPENT MOST OF
HIS DAY SHOVELING BY LIMBO
BETWEEN CABLE NEWS HEADS.
AS LONG AS HE CONTINUES TO
DENOUNCE PEOPLE AS A RECESS, THE
RIGHT PEOPLE, HE CAN PROBABLY
KEEP THAT JOB FOREVER.
SO NATURALLY HE HAS NO INTEREST
IN EXPLAINING HOW EXACTLY RACISM
MAKES PEOPLE A TARGET.
AS HE TOLD VIEWERS AT MSNBC,
IT’S ALL ABOUT THE "CONTEXT."
>> HUMAN BEINGS NATURAL
INCLINATION WHILE THEY FEEL
WRONG, WHEN THEY FEEL PUT UPON,
WHEN THEY ARE LIVING UNDER THESE
CONDITIONS, TO LASH OUT.
IT’S A HISTORY OF THE WORLD AND
SUMMARIES.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO IS UNDERSTAND
THE CONTEXT OF WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: THE CONTEXT.
SQUINT YOUR EYES, THE CONTEXT.
OF COURSE.
THERE’S A CONTEXT OF SETTING
FIRE TO McDONALD’S.
IT’S INTERESTING.
SO YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW WOULD
EDDIE CLOW JR. RESPONDED
SOMETHING LIKE THIS HAPPEN TO
HIM?
IF LOOTERS DESCENDED ON HIS
HOUSE?
WOULD HE GENTLY DESCRIBE THEM AS
PROTESTERS?
IF THEY SMASHED THE WINDSHIELD
OF HIS BMW WITH ROCKS, WOULD
EDDIE CLOW TO CALL THE POLICE
OVER CALLING THE POLICE BE
RACIST?
JUST HOW LONG IN OTHER WORDS
COULD EDDIE CLOUD MAINTAIN HIS
FRAUDULENT RACIAL JUSTICE SHTICK
SHTICK, AND LET’S HOPE NONE OF
US IS TESTED.
THEY ARE UNPREDICTABLE AND
MORTALLY DANGEROUS.
SIGNS APPEAR OR AUTHORIZING, WE
HAVE A LOT OF THOSE IN THIS
COUNTRY OVER THE YEARS AND
THERE’S NOTHING WORSE THAN THAT.
WATCH THE CITY’S POLICE CHIEF
EXPLAIN WHY HE DOESN’T PLAN TO
DO ANYTHING AT ALL TO STOP
WRITERS.
>> WHAT THEY ARE SAYING IS IT’S
TOO DANGEROUS FOR POLICE TO
DIRECTLY CONFRONT THE LOOTERS,
SO YOU’VE MADE THE DECISION TO
LET THAT SITE GO FOR NOW AND
FOCUS ON KEEPING THE REST OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND MY SAFETY IS PARAMOUNT.
I DON’T WANT THEM TO GO INTO AN
AREA WHERE THEY ARE AT RISK OF
HARMING THEMSELVES.
>> Tucker: IT’S PERFECTLY
BACKWARD.
THE SAFETY OF THE CITIZENS,
ESPECIALLY THE WEEK AS CITIZENS
AND THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE POLICE
IN THE FIRST PLACE, TO PROTECT
PEOPLE THAT CANNOT ACT
THEMSELVES.
AND THAT’S FINE TO DO SOMETHING
ELSE BUT, WE MIGHT GET HURT
UNFORTUNATELY, OUR APOLOGIZED.
THINGS ARE FALLING APART.
AND AS THEY COLLAPSE, OUR
LEADERSHIP CLASS SEEMS THRILLED.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE A
PIECE JUST THIS MORNING WITH THE
TITLE "HOW WHITE WOMEN USE
THEMSELVES AS INSTRUMENTS OF
TERROR."
THE SUBHEADING READ THIS WAY
"THERE ARE TOO MANY NEWEST AND
NEXT, CHARRED BODIES AND DROWNED
SOULS FOR THEM TO DENY KNOWING
PRECISELY WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
"WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, THEM?
BUT THEY ARE DOING?
KEEP IN MIND, AND EVERY SINGLE
PERSON OF A CERTAIN COLOR AND
SACKS HAS A HAND IN.
THEY ARE SUSTAINED BY BLOOD
GUILT.
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE OUR LEADERS
ARE ACTUALLY TALKING LIKE THIS
BUT THEY ARE, A LOT, AND LOUDLY.
IF THEY KEEP IT UP, THINGS WILL
NOT END WELL AND YET THEY SHOW
NO SIGNS OF SLOWING DOWN.
WATCH AS TWO OF CNN’S LEADING
LIGHTS GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE
NATIONAL EMERGENCY WE ARE LIVING
THROUGH.
THEY’VE DISCOVERED WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT, 100%
RESPONSIBLE.
THEY KNOW WHO’S GUILTY.
HERE’S THE HINT, IT’S AN ENTIRE
RACIAL GROUP.
>> IT IS NOT INCUMBENT UPON
BLACK PEOPLE TO STOP RACISM, IT
IS INCUMBENT UPON PEOPLE WHO
HOLD THE POWER IN THE SOCIETY TO
HELP DO THAT, TO DO THE HEAVY
LIFTING.
AND GUESS WHO THAT IS?
WHO IS THAT?
WHITE PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THE FUNNY THING IS,
THESE ARE THE VERY SAME PEOPLE
WHO CLAIM THEY ARE FIGHTING
"YOUR RACISM.
BUT THE PROBLEM IS MUCH BIGGER
THIS TIME THAN MERE HYPOCRISY.
WE ARE USED TO THAT.
THIS PROBLEM IS FAR MORE HONEST,
ACCURATE IS IN THREE SENTENCES.
THERE ARE 320 MILLION OF US IN
THIS COUNTRY.
A LOT OF US ARE VERY DIFFERENT
FROM ONE ANOTHER YET, WE ALL
HAVE TO LIVE TOGETHER.
IN FACT, MOST OF US WANT TO LIVE